You get what it means to be social,...
...but do you understand the opportunity it represents for your business?
Social business unlocks the true power of people.
Engage them with dynamic, highly personalized experiences and social forums,...
...where they can share opinions and voice concerns.
Gain valuable insights to anticipate changing demands in real-time.
Delivering new levels of customer intimacy and loyalty.
Simplify the way customers interact with your organization...
...across channels and around the world.
Gain the ability to compete with and win against the world's best.
Attract the right employees using innovative sourcing techniques...
...that tap into hidden pools of talents.
Enable your workforce to connect the ways in which it works and communicates.
Aligning skills with organizational needs.
Inspire employees to create the products and services your customers want today,...
...and to predict the needs that will exist tomorrow.
Integrate how your people engage with each other and customers,...
...using their expertise to create value across your enterprise.
IBM Social Business: generate unprecedented value.
Get social, do business.